I was in New York and this guy comes up
to me and he's like yo
will or like Fresh Prince like what
should I call you and I was like yo like
you know call me Jabari
[Music]
ations
oh my God okay so you look great I'd
love to see you oh wow oh God
season two what are the memories that
you all get when you when you sit in
this foyer hours and hours
it's not in here but it's uh it's right
over in the kitchen when we're doing
that breakfast scene are you talking
about the one we're catching
it was like how we're like because we
had done that scene all day and finally
I was just cracking up I get tired I
started to have laughs and also it was
my life
that was like my first like one of my
first scenes eating um
I'm excited just to be back for season
two people think of us as like these
people who just do this show right but
you know we're all up to so many things
so like Coco like somehow this woman was
able to release a whole album of songs I
could sing some of them for you but
you're really good
how has it been for you trying to
balance both these careers at the same
time I think if I could have my own
perfect world I would be able to have
acting and music start at different
times in the year but they definitely
bleed into each other pretty much every
other day sometimes I feel like
pressured honestly because they're both
very important to me I would not have an
EP project if I didn't leave this set
and go to the studio every night you
know like how would I get the songs to
pick from you know what I'm saying and I
want it to be a reflection of me so I
have to give it my all and that just
means I'm giving all of myself to do
things
100 twice I know yeah that's a scary
part so tell me why we're not
celebrating you having a paying job
because Mom I'm not sure about some of
the requirements they were asking for of
me it's a position at home Cuisine is
this not what you've been building
towards what I've been building towards
or what you've been building towards I
feel like as artists we always get kind
of get put in a box right it's like you
do this thing and especially too when
you're like playing an iconic role like
what has been the biggest negative
there's always a lot of pictures and a
lot of just attention when you're just
doing you feeling like you like this
because I love people I was in New York
and this guy comes up to me and he's
like yo will or like Fresh Prince like
what should I call you and I was like yo
like you know call me Jabari like my
name is jabard you know and so it's it's
interesting the purpose of even why
we're here right now is to speak about
that yeah like who is Ali damn that's
crazy well I wanna I wanna eat you got
by 30. first is a crazy goal but I think
that in setting unrealistic goals for
myself I think it's I think it helps me
Excel but also it's kind of a
double-edged sword right because when
you don't hit those goals I think
there's an element of oh I'm not good
enough or an element of if I had just
when in reality you know sometimes with
the way this business is there is no if
I adjust stuff will happen when it and
like I feel like you you both can speak
to this more like if you got it what's
up right
you're right you just put the work in
where focus goes energy flows so if you
focus on what you want everything else
that you want will fall into place if
you just give it the you know attention
that it needs at the time if our
situation came to light will wouldn't be
the only one that suffers so all those
lectures you gave me about Justice
and following the rules of doing the
right thing that was all
you guys have had these long careers and
I'm curious how did you feel about the
trajectory of your lives and being here
now being this part of culture like is
it how you thought it would pan out for
you guys
I mean I just wanted to be a part of a
narrative that was going to inspire and
and you know be important to the culture
and so yes this is a blessing I just
didn't know how what form it was going
to come in and I would have never
thought in a million years I'd be
playing Uncle Phil all right right Uncle
Phil this daddy
but honestly I just let go and let God
and I'm just grateful to be here I mean
I always thought my career would be sort
of exactly what it is like this this
like buffet and I'm like there's so many
choices so I never saw myself like I'm
only gonna act you know I was like oh
I'm Gonna Act I'm gonna do some stand up
I should do you know I'm gonna build a
company which I'm building a company
right now called creatricity when I
started at 15 years old in ninth grade
starting acting I always knew I'd be an
actor and every time someone would say
you know some of you in this room will
be major actors but most of you won't it
never occurred to me he wasn't talking
to me I was like I'm obviously the
person is
if you heard that part of that it's not
you and you believed it then it's not
you I'm saying that maybe I shouldn't
accept this Fellowship
I mean they'd want me lecturing all over
the world for a year and we're going to
need somebody here to hold down the home
front
I can do that
let me do that
SDA
Phil you are not superhuman it's a very
one percenter mindset right you don't
think put that in any category though
not just I agree it was so inspiring to
be around artists who love art in the
same way that I did because I you know
when you surround yourself with people
who have that same ambition it's really
fulfilling and I think that's about the
first day I met you and we did this even
on Zoom I remember being like Oh man
talk about being born for something
foreign
what has been your experience working
with all of us I mean we're all a lot
older than you
I feel like working with
the cast older than me I learned so much
being on set learning how to be patient
and to stay focused how do you even
balance your personal life and your
education life all with this show I
didn't even realize that you went to
school I thought school was here well I
do like online school but I also go in
person sometimes because I still like to
have the dynamic of being a regular kid
other than you know being in the
industry and all this stuff so when I go
home I'm just secure but when I'm like
on Saturday
I gotta do laundry siblings girl you
working yes take care of all my siblings
literally like I have a little brother
and I'm over here holding him in one arm
making cereal in the other arm
it's really like cats making cereals
she's like oh my God
so what is
schools like when I first went to that
school I was fully in person I didn't
tell anybody my Instagram that I was
like on anything because I just like if
they found out then they found out but I
also just want to separate it like I
don't want people to know like that if
it was up to you would you have them not
know it all yeah really because they
just act so different and that's why I
don't really have any friends on school
I just don't know what their intentions
are stop you make me cry you're gonna
make me cry no like purposely I would
just say like I feel like you already
know you have like core people around
you and that's the most important thing
like but also I I kind of taught myself
to like categorize people because yeah
sometimes you want to go out with people
and you know okay they're looking at me
a little differently they do not see me
as normal but I know that that's who
they are and they're put in that box and
then I know I have these other people
who are actually rooting for me and I'll
tell them when I'm really sad or when I
have something that's really going on
yeah I don't think that you have to
completely close yourself off because
you're going to be much bigger than you
are right now you'll probably get your
egot at 25. Hill
so I have this friend that I have a
crush on
and I think this one likes me but hasn't
said that
what do I do does a friend have a name
Lucia
that's a pretty name remember after our
first table read and I was like yo like
we're gonna be willing Carlton like
let's go hang out and we drove around La
we were so wide-eyed at how our lives
are about to change right we didn't know
that we didn't really know yeah now
what's happened and now we're going to
think of it I think it's amazing because
we're taking on these iconic characters
that the world already knows how do you
make sure you don't lose yourself in
that man it's that's a tough question
because you know what's crazy I I used
to wear this hoop earring in my left ear
last season
and I wore that up until maybe July of
2022. so that was like after we had
stopped filming season one I was still
will probably be different than will I
think it's when I separate from the
camera from the lights from everybody I
get to like tap into an artistic side
like if it was me like I would shave my
head and dye it pink
I did that and I did that and but that's
Jamar like that's that's me unless um I
guess put together than that sure and
did you do that to to separate yourself
after we finished shooting just so that
you could feel like yourself yeah yeah
to a degree to a degree because I felt
so much like well I think my whole life
people have told me like oh man you you
kind of resemble well or you have his
energy and so like I've always seen
myself as like he I'm an extension of
him and even more so now and how do you
deal with being an extension of the
biggest movie star maybe in the history
of existence it's a lot of crazy it's a
lot of pressure for sure I could be a
lot of pressure but I take the pressure
off of it like I I wake up every day and
I just want to have fun because I just
see this as such a blessing well let's
salute you for the incredible work that
you've brought to the show and just the
energy and just the foundation that
you've helped create here because
without you we would not have this stuff
I'll learn from it
I learn from it
because I'm the one that got snatched
out of Philly and sent out here to Bel
Air me
not you me what do you think is the most
rewarding part and challenging part of
being on Bel Air for me the most
rewarding part of being on Bel Air is
getting to be a part of a narrative that
is so relevant to the the current
temperatures that we're in and the
culture the biggest challenge for me is
I don't live here there have been times
where I'm just like in the makeup chair
and I just start crying because because
I I come home to an empty house right
I'm so mad at you I live 15 minutes from
you yeah
[Applause]
I'm in that makeup chair or when I'm
even like about to come on set and I get
really heavy I have certain things I do
to try to keep me my head above water
when I feel really anxious and sad about
it the main thing I do is I send so many
videos to my son and we send videos back
and forth I'm like hey this is what
Mommy's doing and he'll send me a video
and then I think to myself the best
thing that you can ever do as a parent
is to show your kid how happy you are
because if your kid sees how happy you
are they assume that they're the thing
that makes you happy as well baby I know
this hasn't been easy but your father
and I wouldn't ask you to do anything we
didn't think you were capable of
we love you and you will always be our
first priority so like obviously you're
Carlton yeah you know I mean you've got
so much hate and animosity online for
your obviously like fantastic portrayal
of Carl's I think you could not take a a
toll on you there is a little part of me
and it's the little kid part of me that
remembers in middle school when I first
came to the states uh they used to call
me melon head yeah yeah and like it's
funny now to think about and this kind
of feeds into
my my slight anxiety about being in
public sometimes which is that
I think it bleeds over I've had people
like grab me before oh yeah all the time
really um I've had people like grab me
of like yo when I saw you on that show I
wanted to and it's like I totally get it
but you did grab me from behind you know
yeah
you grab my shoulder it's like yes I get
it you're making a joke but like I
listen I thought I was about to get my
ass beat right now
you know
like to see honestly just because I want
to give you your flowers because you are
such a vital part of the success of the
show and you are the most complicated
character yes thank you
you are
you stopped me from using today
I was this close right after you left
but then I thought about what you said
so I'm letting you know
thank you beyond Hillary Beyond Bel Air
I'm definitely a musician singer
I do it because I love music you know
what I'm saying like that has to be it
has to be done to get where I want to go
but
beyond all that I'm really just regular
Beyond Ashley I think I spend most of my
time with my family and I am an activist
for mental health it's super important
to check up on people and make sure that
they're doing good because you never
know what people are going through I
feel that there's a lot of things that I
I want to do but I feel like this has
always been my biggest dream this is
telling stories being a Storyteller I'm
like the most chaotic woman I really am
just the most chaotic person I know if I
wasn't doing this I'd probably be like
an interior designer or yeah yeah I love
interior design I thought you're gonna
say fashion because you'll be dripped
down I love fashion too I'm a musician
as well and I have music coming out soon
and I'm super excited about it I'm not
just funny I'm not just academic minded
I love people and I just want to be of
service to people and I also want to
bring the best out people I'm Molly
scholaton I am a musician I am an actor
I'm a music producer I'm a writer
gentleman
I love to create and
in the idea of creating as a living has
been
I think the only dream I've ever had and
it's really special to get to do it with
uh with all of you
[Music]
now I've always wanted to do a round
table situation so yeah
all right well I love y'all
[Music]